the april inflation data just came in
and boy is it bad breaking news 8.3
year-over-year change in consumer prices
now of course that is above expectations
nothing new as we have seen for the last
two years the federal reserve economists
and talking heads all on television they
continue to understate and under expect
what is going to happen with inflation
now if we dig into the data charlie
bolillo breaking down exactly where that
inflation is being derived from first
you can see that gasoline is up 43
over the last 12 months if you look at
something like new cars it's up 13
even though they are actually
manipulating the way that that is
calculated then the big one to me is
food at home up 10.8 over the last 12
months that is completely unsustainable
for the average american family food
away from home not much better at 7.2
percent and then shelter shelter at 5.1
increase over the last 12 months now
part of the problem is that nobody
believes the cpi metrics they're
literally manipulating the way that it's
calculated we see that new cars all of a
sudden yesterday gets announced that
they're going to change the way they
calculate those price increases and then
you look at something like shelter
they're telling us that rent is up close
to 20 year-over-year on the national
average home price is up about 20
national average so how the hell is
shelter only up 5 well that's because of
course nobody believes this number is
only 8.3 the real inflation rate in the
united states is probably closer to
about 15 percent that means that the
average american family is suffering
it's not a good situation and until the
federal reserve and politicians step in
and start to actually change things this
isn't going away anytime soon if we go
ahead and we take a look around the
world you can see the united states it's
at the bottom of the list you can see
here that the us at 8.3 percent is only
better than spain netherlands brazil
poland russia argentina turkey and
venezuela it's not exactly the list that
you want to be listed on if you're the
united states but also a key thing to
look to in the future is that there's
gonna be a base effect remember last
year starting around june inflation went
over five percent it's been over five
percent since and so now if inflation
number comes down that's just the
year-over-year change but it actually
means that we're compounding at five
percent or more inflation year-over-year
and that is not good situation and so
expect for that inflation number to come
down it peaked in march at 8.5 in april
is 8.3 that means inflation's actually
getting better it just means that
there's a base effect at play here and
that inflation is still raging on the
federal reserve is going to have to
increase interest rates and they're
going to have to address the situation
because if they don't inflation is quite
literally going to tax everyone